- Have you been trying
to be an influencer?
I've seen this.
I follow you.
You're hysterical.
- I am hysterical.
- You are!
(Whitney laughs)
You are!
I'm telling you,
and I'm being honest,
like, in such a hard
summer for a lot of us,
it's such nice escapism.
Humor is so healing.
- It's so healing.
- I'm not joking.
I literally go on Twitter to find you-
- Aw, I love you!
- Just to read your stuff
when I'm having a crap day.
- I love you!
- No, 'cause it's funny!
And it's nice, and it's helpful,
'cause it's like, okay,
we're gonna laugh again
at some point.
- There's this narrative that
like the country's so divided
and everyone hates each other.
I don't believe that.
I think there is a lot of that out there,
but I think that, you know,
I love doing stand-up because
you get a bunch of people
in a room that don't know each other
and probably voted differently,
and they can all laugh at the same stuff.
You know-
- Yeah.
That's how I feel about concerts-
- Yes! That's what music does, too!
It brings people together,
and you know, so.
So, during this time,
it's been getting very risky
in some of the videos
and stuff we're making
just to try to make you
guys laugh at all costs.
Benton, my assistant, has
been putting me in danger
constantly to try to
make funny TikTok videos.
- I was gonna say, your TikTok videos,
the one with the wine
was one of my favorites.
When you're drinking-
- Well, all my TikTok videos involve wine.
(Kelly laughs)
But that one, I just drank it on camera.
Oh, yes!
There it is!
- This is my favorite!
(Whitney laughs)
- This is a TikTok challenge
where you try to like
sort of like put the wine in your mouth
and the other person drinks it.
I didn't like it,
'cause I like the wine
to get down my gullet
as quickly as possible.
(Kelly laughs)
And yeah, so Benton keeps
putting me in all these
crazy dangerous TikTok challenges,
which a lot of them are
really actually very scary,
and I have to tell him like,
"You know you're not in my will, right?"
(Kelly laughs)
"If I die..."
"I don't know why you're
trying to kill me so badly!"